Hello Freak bitches under 2.5.
Wow.
Wow,
wow,
interesting.
Um,
yeah,
but the only way Mcgregor's going to win,
I think if it's under the two and a half.
Oh No,
not in an under two and a half,
but by stoppage I think.
Yeah.
Only to imagine him out boxing.
No,
that ain't happening yet.
You're living in a rung fucking planet if you think you've seen to help box,
unless he figures out a way to a mall.
I'm like,
he's done a style like he's doing with withholding the back of the head and
throwing punches.
But that's after he's worn Paulie out.
I,
I think you're going to see,
I think you would see Connor using his footwork still that distance trying to,
you know,
still do what got them to the dance.
He might,
what if he drops one on Floyd and Floyd go stiff face plants.
I would love that.
I think he's going to land one on Floyd.
I think so.
I think Kinda when's the spectacle?
The probably loses in decision,
but if there is a stoppage it's ICAN or knocking them out.
Well,
you know we're talking today about them going to eight ounce gloves and how how
significant the official commission just granted it that first of all,
it shows you,
you can just,
you can just pull those commissioners aside and go,
what's these rule like a slowly drug testing.
Why are we talking about rules?
Let's have some fun here.
Let's have some fun.
I wonder if WME came along like when they bought the UFC.
What?
Boy that was what the Assata Guy?
Yeah.
What's,
we need him.
What's up with the golden snowing?
We got about another six months.
We listen.
Let's just direct that guy towards weight.
Cut It.
You just have him like folks on the gas and the undercarriage and we do that.
We get out of this.
You've shot of them for rails backing up,
backing up percent.
Hundred percent.
Well,
Andre Berto said when he fought Floyd,
he's never been tested more in his life.
He was like four times a week they'd knock on my door like dressed up like
agents.
That's what he says.
He goes,
are you testing Floyd like this?
They go,
that's none of your concern.
He was just the promoters obligation as the promoters.
Floyd Mayweather.
He goes,
you'll figure it out.
He just kept getting tested nonstop.
Yeah.
He wants more of your blood.
He wants you to make you tired,
you know?
I'll tell you what though.
I don't know what the drug tests and it's like on this bad boy,
but with Alvarez fight,
it was interesting because he made canela get down to one 50 you know they
fought at one 50 and can,
they always makes people to come to him.
Like you have to play by his rules and his fight though.
That's what's so scary.
That's why I tip my hat to Floyd because he went out with fight at one 54 that's
like,
that's all right.
That's perfect for Connor.
Yeah.
I would do a dance clubs.
What the Farrell's?
Yeah,
yeah,
we'll do that.
We all take on short notice to this motherfucker is crazy.
I just think he thinks he's so good.
He might just not understand like first of all,
Connor is whether or not you're,
you're looking at his success inside the octagon,
which had been pretty spectacular,
but it's the way he's doing things.
He's got this best show fucking air about him and this very psychotic belief in
himself.
It's a d,
it's not a fake belief.
No,
he's not.
He's not trying to con anybody.
He's trying to manifest like some sort of miraculous existence.
He's trying to be the guy who literally goes in there and drops and smashes
Floyd Mayweather as a UFC fighter and then becomes with that the biggest athlete
on the planet earth ever maybe ever,
ever.
If he flatlines Floyd Mayweather,
Floyd Mayweather steps in and Connor fucking karate stance stances him and blast
them with a straight left hand and we see Floyd stiffen up and face plant North
Korea nukes where we're going to turn the ocean green shit.
Okay,
this we're all,
we're going to manufacture all of the color,
that green color that you put in drinks on Saint Patrick's day,
pouring that shit in the ocean.
We're making the ocean green just all great.
Just huge statues of Conor do going to have people that are faking Irish
accents.
That's sort of like that.
Rachel Dolezal chick pretended to be black,
is going to be people that are changing.
Oh,
on the tiger tattoos on their chest.
They're going to change themselves and become Irish.
They're going to be trans.
It'll get,
that's what the world's going to dunk.
What is that?
When did that happen?
Cargo on Saint Patrick's Day,
they do it really?
Other fish oil on everything.
They really don't do it every year.
Oh my God,
we're so gross.
People are so gross.
Let's have some fun and get fucking hammered and make the ocean greed.
Woo.
The fish are like,
what the fuck?
Okay.